when you're a leader when you're a  manager or an owner of a business AI  really is an opportunity for Innovation  and creativity here we're talking more  about small and medium Enterprises who  want to launch their journey of AI and  need a bit of a boost and some help  along the way  [Music]  Mila has a large number of activities  including the new AI activation program  which often takes the form of adversary  Mendes of a few months to support the  organization in their Advanced use of AI  the smes are probably the type of  businesses that have the greatest  challenge to digitize and to incorporate  Ai and we can help them in several ways  with just a few hours of talking trying  to understand what they're doing the  kind of data they may have we can help  them strategize at Mila what we're  thinking about are different programs  that can help support accelerate  companies at different stages as they go  about their Journey  foreign